So who is my guest this week?
The Grand Slam tennis
champion, Andy Murray.
The career span of an
elite athlete can be short,
but this British tennis player
has already packed a hell
of a lot into his 35 years,
three Grand Slam wins and
a former world number one,
he's battled injury to
remain on the court,
bagging tens of millions
of dollars along the way.
But for the greatest UK
player since Virginia Wade,
it's always been about
more than the money.
He's turned down endorsements
and done things his own way.
From his early years,
when some of the public
were unsure of him,
he's now ranked by pollsters
as the most popular tennis
player in the world.
As he faces what could
be his last Wimbledon,
what does he do next?
And can he avoid the pitfalls that occur
for so many top sports players
once they've quit their game?
This is what's coming up.
I know we're talking ahead
of Wimbledon, of course.
Do you have to go in
believing you can win again?
Yeah, I mean, I think that's
part of the motivation
to still be out there competing.
I know it's gonna be even
harder to win Wimbledon
than it was five, six years ago,
but yeah, I still believe,
and I'm still working
and training as hard as I can
to try and try and achieve that goal.
You've been very influenced
by strong women in your life,
not least your mum,
the pro tennis coach,
of course, Judy Murray,
and she recently wrote an article
about being sexually
assaulted at an awards dinner
by a man sat next to her.
I was obviously really upset for her.
I was pretty angry, but also,
I didn't know quite exactly what to say.
It's a familiar story for a lot of women,
and yeah, that sort of behavior
shouldn't be tolerated anywhere.
Andy Murray, hello.
Thank you very much for talking to me.
Hi, how are you doing?
Do people call you Sir Andy, ever?
Rarely, no.
I try to avoid that when I can.
Okay, no, no, I mean, you
are, you are a knight,
so I just was remembering that.
Do do your kids ever call you it?
I don't think they're aware of it.
They have started calling me Andy Murray,
which I find pretty awkward.
They tend to do it when they're
around their other friends
to wind me up.
Well, it sounds like
you've taught them well,
to wind you up already.
I love that, Andy Murray,
from your children.
I know we're talking ahead
of Wimbledon, of course,
do you have to go in
believing you can win again?
Yeah, I mean, I think that's
part of the motivation
to still be out there competing.
I know, obviously, that's gonna be
an unbelievably difficult thing to do,
but I do still believe that
I've got great tennis in me.
I know it's gonna be even harder
to win Wimbledon than it
was five, six years ago,
but yeah, I still believe,
and I'm still working
and training as hard as I can
to try and achieve that goal.
Yes, well, I mean, we should say,
in case people don't know,
you've had a lot of pain, injuries,
particularly around your hip,
and I read that you're inspired
by the likes of Muhammad Ali
and sports stars who make big comebacks.
Is that part of the psychology?
For me, I came back to play
tennis because I love it.
That's why I came back to play.
It's been something I've done
since I was a really young kid
and pretty much since my
sort of teenage years,
it's been the main thing in my life,
and I've dedicated a lot of time to it,
and I kind of realized
when I was going through
all of the injuries and pain
and wasn't able to compete
how much I did love it.
And yeah, probably wish, at times,
certainly earlier in my career
that I appreciated it a bit more
and enjoyed it a little
bit more than I did.
Yes, well, I mean, I'm fascinated
by how individuals do cope with pain.
I actually live with a
condition called endometriosis,
so I'm quite regularly in pain.
Of course, everyone's pain
is very subjective to them.
And in your case, it
stopped you at many moments
from doing what you
wanted, what you dream of,
what you train of.
How have you coped with pain?
Well, I think as athletes,
you're used to sort of always
having a certain level of pain
from the training and
the matches that you do,
and that's kind of normal.
So I think most athletes probably have
a relatively high sort of pain tolerance,
but then with my hip,
and I dealt with discomfort in my hip
for probably six or seven years,
until it, basically, from one
day to the next went from,
I was ranked number one
in the world at the time
to I literally can't
walk properly anymore,
and I couldn't extend my
hip and was in constant pain
every time, even when I
went to walk the dogs.
And I think, initially,
that's obviously difficult to deal with,
but I think over time, it's
the consistency of the pain
and it just being every single day
that sort of wore me down.
And I filmed a documentary
during my sort of rehab
and all the injuries and
the surgeries and stuff,
and when I watched that
back, I kind of realized,
which I didn't whilst
I was going through it,
I was in a pretty bad place,
so probably didn't deal
with it particularly well
in the end, but it had been
going on for a long time
and it was stopping me from
doing what I love as well.
And I cannot wait to see
you back at Wimbledon.
I really, really can't.
I did think about, though,
when you were in that state,
and I know about that film,
I've watched film that you made,
I was thinking about whether
you'd got to a place,
but maybe it's premature to ask you this,
but have you thought about
how you will be happy
or satisfied if you never
win another Grand Slam?
Yeah, I mean, look,
I don't expect that to happen.
I still believe that I can do it,
but I got to a point
before I had the operation
that I had to contemplate
not playing tennis again,
and I was fighting and
battling with that as well
during the injury troubles.
And I knew that when I
had the hip resurfacing,
that there was a chance I might
not be able to play again,
and I had to come to terms with that.
Once I did, I feel fine.
I know that I'll be fine
if I had to stop playing tennis tomorrow,
I'll be absolutely fine.
I've got a great family.
I would obviously miss playing tennis,
but I have lots to look forward to
away from the tennis court.
Well, you're a fashion
designer now, right?
You've just been doing a
photo shoot, I believe,
a model and a fashion designer,
your sportswear range, Andy
Murray, let me get this right,
Andy Murray x Castore, that's
your new calling, right?
Yeah, so I mean,
I wouldn't call myself a fashion designer.
I don't know a whole lot
about fashion, to be honest,
but I try and get
involved as much as I can
in terms of the way the clothes
perform on the tennis court.
That's something that interests me a lot,
so I try and help with that.
I test a lot of the kit and everything
before I, obviously, have to perform on it
and give feedback and
try to make improvements
to where I can, but yeah,
I let the fashion designers take care
of the fashion side of things
because I don't know a
whole lot about that.
We can't underestimate
the power of clothes,
and for you, I suppose,
it's something you wrap yourself in.
It's a bit of an armor at the same time.
Yeah, I mean, it is
really important for us,
and the shoes as well.
It can make a difference
to your performance,
and certainly, the clothes
and extreme conditions,
we play in Australia
where it's 40 degrees,
and in places like Miami
where it can be 85, 90% humidity,
so you need to make
sure that the materials
and stuff that you're
wearing are appropriate
for the conditions.
So, yeah, it is important.
I just have to say, I
talked about watching you,
of course, as a Brit,
I feel I've lived many
moments with you on my knees,
standing up, hiding behind the sofa,
willing you on to win,
but one of the things
that I wanted to ask you was
about your kind of fist pump
that you do, and that roar
that you do to the crowd,
what's going on there?
What are you thinking about
when people like me are
watching you do that,
point after point after point?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's just,
well, a little bit is, obviously,
trying to encourage yourself,
but then, yeah, there's moments in a match
where you're trying to
engage with the crowd
that are coming there to watch the tennis,
hopefully be entertained,
but to support one of the
two players out there.
And when people come to
watch sporting events,
they want to see that emotion.
Hopefully, it's positive emotion,
but sometimes, for me,
it's negative as well.
I wish I was able to control
the negative emotions
that I have when I'm playing better,
but I feel like when I do it to the crowd,
and fist pump and get
excited on the court,
that I'm trying to engage the crowd.
No, no, and it's great to,
of course, have crowds back
and feed off that energy.
What do you make of groaning
and grunting whilst playing?
What do you make of that?
Some spectators find that not the best,
but I wonder how it is as a player.
And other spectators love it.
I remember growing up watching
Monica Seles, for instance.
There's a certain level
that I think is okay,
and almost natural when
you're putting lots of effort
into something, but when it's at a level
that sounds and seems unnatural,
then that's when it's maybe
a little bit off putting,
and then some players are
maybe doing it so long
that the ball's already
getting hit by the opponent,
whilst they're grunting,
and that is not good
'cause it should be a hindrance, really.
Yes, it's not their ball
very much at that moment.
No, I can only imagine.
Well, we're just speaking
about, of course, again,
with regards to Wimbledon ahead of it,
you will be very aware of the controversy
going into this Wimbledon
surrounding the decision
to ban Russian and Belarusian players.
You've acknowledged how
complicated this decision is.
You chose your words very carefully,
and you have sympathy for
the players who can't play,
and the authorities who have done this.
It's a really difficult
one, this, isn't it?
Well, my sympathies, first and foremost,
are with the people in Ukraine,
and what they're going through.
In the grand scheme of things,
whether some tennis players
are not able to play
in an event or not,
and whether there's
ranking points on offer,
in the grand scheme of
things, is kind of irrelevant.
Obviously, I know quite a
few of the Russian players
and I'm friends with
them, and I feel for them
that they're not able to compete.
I can appreciate that
may seem unfair to them,
but I can also see Wimbledon's side,
and their point of view and
the perspective that they have,
and it's very complex,
but at the end of it,
there's a war going on.
That's what people should be focusing on,
and we want that to end
as quickly as possible,
and a tennis tournament
isn't really that important,
I don't think.
No, I think that's obviously the context
and a very important one to you,
and I know you're an
ambassador for UNICEF.
I know you're also donating the proceeds
of any of your payments
or winnings this year
to the effort to support children,
in particular, in Ukraine.
But I think what's very
striking about you, Andy,
is you have been outspoken
about a number of issues
over the years, before, almost,
not that it was fashionable,
but people in sport
perhaps taking positions,
whether it's about the mental
health of young players
to sexism in sport, as well,
is something I know you care deeply about.
Do you get more confident
to share opinions
as you get older, or less?
Does it become easier or harder?
I think in some ways it becomes easier
because you're maybe, I don't know,
when you're in your early 20s,
you don't really know much
about anything, really.
And I'm not saying I know loads now,
but I know a lot more now than I did then,
and I maybe trust my
views a little bit better
than I did then.
And I also feel as well,
like since I had children,
that I want to make sure
that I support things
that are important to me,
and that hopefully will
maybe help the world
that my children grow up in as well.
So in some ways, yes, it does,
maybe it does help as you get older,
and maybe it becomes a bit
easier to share your opinions,
but at the same time,
with everything that
goes on online nowadays,
and everything like online abuse,
and those sorts of things,
at times, you think,
"Well, what's the point?
I'll just say nothing
because it's an easier life
that way as well."
And I wanna focus all my
time and energy on my family
and on my tennis, and
when you do get involved
in certain topics and subjects,
it attracts more attention,
more questions, more time,
more comments online, and that
can be quite tiring as well.
Yes, well, I mean, you
mentioned your family there,
of course, as well as
three daughters and a son,
you've been very influenced
by strong women in your life,
not least your mum, the pro tennis coach,
of course, Judy Murray.
And she recently wrote an article,
and I actually remember
reading it when it came out,
and it's a terribly shocking,
but horribly familiar story
to quite a lot of women,
I have to say.
She wrote about being sexually
assaulted at an awards dinner
by a man sat next to her.
I just wonder, did you
know already that story,
and did she tell you she
was going to share it?
My brother was aware of that, I wasn't.
My mum did message me at
the time to let me know
that there was an article
coming out about it.
And yeah, I was obviously
really upset for her.
I was pretty angry,
but also I didn't know
quite exactly what to say.
And obviously, I messaged my mum,
I called her the following
day to talk to her
to make sure that she was okay,
and yeah, like you say,
it's, obviously, a familiar
story for a lot of women,
and yeah, that sort of behavior
shouldn't be tolerated anywhere.
I mean, she also wrote as part of this,
which is a big part of
what your mum has done, is,
"Women are made to feel
the world of sport is not for us,
and our presence is neither
welcome nor important."
And what I mean by that is
your mum has done a lot of work
to try and change that,
to be a big part of the
world of sport she is.
I wonder, when you have
thought about sexism,
and how women are perceived,
you've, of course, also had
a female coach yourself,
that was a big story at the time,
even though it shouldn't
have been in many ways,
how do you stop those men?
It's not all men in sport, of course,
but those men in sport making women feel
like your mum described?
That's a good question,
which I probably don't
know all of the answers to.
I think some of it probably
comes from education,
some of it probably comes
from having more women around
so that it's not something
that it seems out of the norm.
Certainly, I, like you mentioned,
I got a taste of that when
I hired a female coach,
and that was very rare.
On the men's tour and the women's tour,
there's very few women coaches,
and I didn't think much of it at the time
when I hired a female coach.
I'd never personally in my
early 20s thought about it
'cause I'd always seen
all of the top players
all working with male coaches.
I had a conversation with Darren Cahill,
who's one of the top
Australian coaches and he said,
"Well, what about speaking
to some female coaches?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
I mean, why not?
Why wouldn't I do that?
I then went down the route
of employing Amélie Mauresmo,
who is a former world number
one Wimbledon champion,
and even when there was rumors
about me potentially working with her,
the comments that I was
getting from fellow players,
fellow coaches, was something
I'd never experienced before,
and that was when I realized
that there was quite a big problem.
And I think that until
it becomes the norm,
that there is more than just the odd one
or two female coaches on
the tour of 200 or 300,
I think that it's probably
always gonna be an issue,
but I mean, hopefully,
things are changing slowly.
Yes, I mean, I suppose when
we look at the world of sport,
and I know I'm broadening
this out slightly,
but I know you will have seen this,
that recently Jake Daniels
became the first active
footballer to come out as gay.
A lot of people have
said that was very brave
because of football, and
how football is perceived,
and how it is to be a footballer,
when it comes to being
open about your sexuality.
I wonder, when we talk
about the world of sport,
what was your reaction to that?
And do you think it is getting better
in being more reflective
of the wider population
and not the world it
thinks it should present,
but the world as it is?
I do think it is getting a bit better.
And I think that that was really positive
that he felt comfortable
enough to come out,
and from what I've seen,
most of the coverage
has been extremely positive about it
in the media.
How that will play out at football grounds
up and down the country,
that will be, I guess, a bigger test.
And hopefully his experience
is really positive as well.
But yeah, you would think that,
certainly in tennis,
there's been no male tennis
players have come out as gay
whilst they've still been playing.
A few have come out post career,
so we maybe have to ask the question
as to why that is the case
and why they still don't feel comfortable
to come out whilst they're still active,
but I would hope that it
would be viewed positively
by all of the players,
and that's certainly been
the case on the female side.
So I didn't actually know that
about male tennis players.
I haven't looked into that,
but that's also interesting.
I mean, is it, particularly
behind the scenes,
I don't know when you're on tour,
is there a lot of bravado
and having to be macho,
and I say that in inverted commas,
sort of being one way?
Do you think that's what it's
about, the conformity perhaps?
I haven't seen it in terms of sexuality.
I think in sport, there is always,
well, certainly in male sport,
about being tough and being a real man,
and not showing any emotions
and those sorts of things,
and whether something like
that would play a part in it,
I've certainly found it difficult at times
earlier in my career to open
up to the coaches and stuff
that were around me because, I don't know,
showing emotions and these
sorts of things were always seen
as kind of being a weakness, you know?
So I've seen it in that sense,
but not in the locker rooms
around someone's sexuality.
Yeah, but I mean,
you've also spoken a
lot about mental health
and how younger players, in particular,
do need more support, especially
to try and be themselves
when they suddenly find
themselves in the spotlight.
You mentioned, there, emotions
and how you were early on in your career.
I did spy just before we started to talk
a recent Instagram post of
you smiling very broadly,
holding a cup of coffee,
saying "After years of being miserable
and incapable of smiling,
I wish I'd known that all
I needed was a coffee."
Is it fun owning that view,
some people had a view,
that you didn't really
seem that happy at first?
Well, I wasn't that happy.
I was happy in certain aspects,
but I didn't feel comfortable
in front of a camera.
My life changed almost overnight
from the first time I played in Wimbledon
as an 18-year-old, and
got to the third round,
and I wasn't ready for that.
I wasn't prepared for that.
It's difficult, I think,
to prepare anyone,
to have that, to sort of no
one in the streets knowing you,
and you're just you just playing tennis
and playing in front of 10, 15 people,
to, all of a sudden,
playing on the Center Court
at Wimbledon with millions
of people watching on the TV,
and getting followed by
paparazzi back to your house,
and those sorts of things,
and seeing your face on
papers and everything,
and comments and things
that you might have said
to your friends that you
maybe made the mistake
of saying in front of a camera,
all of a sudden you
were getting sent abuse,
people saying stuff to
you up in the streets
and these sorts of things,
and it is really difficult.
And you, then, would I think, naturally
go into your shell and
not want to open up,
and just put up a bit of a shield.
And that's certainly what I did,
and was not that happy
being in front of a camera,
and did not feel comfortable in it.
And it's my responsibility how I deal
with that side of things,
but yeah, I don't think
the media helped me
through that period,
and I don't think that
probably enough is done
to help young athletes prepare themselves
for the spotlight at such a young age.
I am praying that you're
going to win Wimbledon.
Thank you, me too.
Are you praying or are you training?
A bit of both?
I'm training, I don't pray.
Okay, I'm not sure I've
put it quite into prayer,
but I'm really hoping,
let's put it like that.
And when you roar with each fist pump,
I'll be thinking of what you
were saying about all of this,
and it's a pleasure to
talk to you, Andy Murray.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
And thank you for being with us.
Until next time, stay safe and goodbye.